25 versus 35 your skin does not need the same thing
and this is where I think a lot of people get this wrong
pink one pdrn it's amazing for hydration
glow and barrier support
it helps your skin recover and look healthy
think glass skin but once you get into your 30s
your skin needs so much more than hydration
this is EGF+
NAD+AD helps to support your skin cellular energy and repair
EGF is this magical signal
that basically tells your skin to regenerate
into reduce more collagen
so this isn't just surface level glow
think of it like this Peter
and helps to maintain your skin
EGF and NAD+ helps to renew your skin is the dream team right here
but if you were over 30 I would go with the EGF and NAD+
this is already selling like crazy
they just launched this deeper than just glow
it's regeneration no wonder they can't keep it on the shelves
hurry grab it in the link below before it's gone